she may have seen the news reports this
afternoon the chairman of the Senate
Intelligence Committee sold more than a
million dollars in stock in mid-february
after learning how devastating the
Chinese crota virus could be he had
inside information about what could
happen to our country which is now
happening but he didn't warn the public
he didn't give a prime-time address he
didn't go on television to sound the
alarm
he didn't even disavow an op-ed he'd
written just 10 days before claiming was
America was quote better prepared than
ever for coronavirus he didn't do any of
those things instead what did he do he
dumped his shares in hotel stocks so he
wouldn't lose money and then he stayed
silent now maybe there's an honest
explanation for what he did if there is
he should share it with the rest of us
immediately otherwise he must resign
from the Senate and face prosecution for
insider trading there is no greater
moral crime than betraying your country
in a time of crisis and that's appeared
that appears to be what happened we'll
have more on the story tomorrow